で ここまであのアンゴリマーラというあの人の話を続けてきました
そこでまあアンゴリマーラが住んでいたこの森の中にお釈迦様が入りまして
でお釈迦様を追っていくんですね
まあ捕まって殺そう殺そうとして
でもなかなかお釈迦様には近寄れなくなっちゃったんですね
で 自分が息切れになっちゃって
これが大変不思議なことになりましたし
彼がまあこれを信じられないんですね
まあ今まで誰が来ても自分が走って捕まって殺したのに
この全力で走っている自分にごく普通のありてて
お釈迦様に近寄れないのはどういうことかと
そこでお釈迦様に彼が待てと言うんですよ
ティトゥ・バガヴァんタン・エタダ・ヴォーチャ
自分がもう走れないんですよ
もう止まっちゃったんですね
止まってお釈迦様にこういうことを言うのです
ティタ・サマナ・ティタ・サマナーティ
シャモン待ちなさいよ
そうするとお釈迦様がティト・アハン・アンゴリマーラ
アンゴリマーラ 私はもう止まって待ってますと
ティタっていうのは止まるっていうことで
止まってますと トゥアン・ティッター・ヒーティ
お前が止まりなさいと
でお釈迦様 実は歩いてるんですね
わざと歩いていながらそういうことを言うんですよ
アンゴリマーラ私は止まってますけど
君止まりなさいと アンゴリマーラ君は止まりなさいと
アタコ・チョーラス・アンゴリマーラッサ・エタダ・ボーシ
そこでアンゴリマーラ泥棒にはこのような考え方が生まれたんだと
イメーコ・サマナー・サッキャ・プッティヤ・サッチャパーティパンナー
このサマナー・サッキャ・プッティヤ
シャカ族 シャカ息子って意味なんで
サッキャ・プッティヤというのはシャカの子供ということで
サマナーっていうのはシャモンで
サッキャ・プッティヤっていうのはシャカ尊の弟子たちって意味なんですね
弟子にも息子というふうな言葉を使うんです
で このシャカ弟子のサモンたちがサッチャ・ワーディノ
いわゆる真理を語る主義ですよ
真理主義者って いわゆる偽りを語らない主義ですよ
サッチャ・ワーディ サッチャ・パティパンナー
嘘は言わないというその性格はもう就いてるんですね
いわゆるその実践を その行為をしているんですね
いわゆる主義としても
まあ真理を語る主義で
主義だけで終わるんじゃなくて
その生き方もしているんですね
サッチャ・ワーディ サッチャ・パティンニャー
アタ・チャ・パナーヤン・サマノ・ガッチャン・ゲーワ・アーハ
なのにこのシャモンはガッチャン・ゲーワ歩き歩いているのにも関わらず
このように言います ティト・アハン
私は止まってますけど
アンゴリマーラ トゥアン・チェ・ティッター・ヒット
トゥアン・チェ 君も止まってみなさいと
君も止まりなさいと 私は止まっている
君も止まりなさいと言うんだと
ヤンノー・ナアハン・イマン・サマナン・プッチェ・イアンティ
これを聞かなくちゃいけない
これは聞いてみようではないかと
明らかに嘘をついているんだから
では聞いてみようではないかと
アタコ・チョーロ・アンゴリマーラ・バガヴァんタン・ガーター・アッジャワーセ
そこでアンゴリマーラが言ったことは
もう芸にしてこちらにあるんだということで
まあいわゆる詩にして質問しましたと
で 寸時にそこさに詩なんか語れるかとかいうこともね
まあわかりませんですけど
いきなり何か歌で質問するっていうのはね
まあもしかするとこの質問する場合は
やっぱりもう形式道徳やらもう厳しい世界だから
まあ他の世界とは違って
その宗教文化の国でしょうし
だからまあ誰かに質問するとそれなりの形式というものがあります
これかなりインドの宗教家の中ではもうきちんと定めてあったんですね
ですから この宗教同士で争いというのは昔はなかったんですね
それぞれみんな違う理論
論理を語っているんだということは知っていて
論争もするし 負けた人は勝った人の教えを信じることにもするし
で だけど他の人にまた負けちゃうと
その宗教に行ってしまっちゃうし
だからまあそういういくらかの自由な生き方はしていましたし
ですから この宗教家の間では
特に哲学者やらね 先生たちの間ではもう厳しくしきたりというのが決まってあって
誰が誰に質問したってもいいんですよ
その場合はこの決まりというのは守らなくちゃいけないんでしょうしね
いい加減に質問したってもいけないし
無責任に質問してもいけないし
ただ聞きたかっただけやという風にね
ただ頭に何か浮かんだだけで
そういう現代的な質問っていうのはもうはない
本当に真剣で質問する
それに真剣に答える もういい加減ということはないんですね
ですから きちんと形式的にお釈迦様に質問を出すだということですよ
だから 形式的な質問だから
言葉はちゃんと決められなく
決めなくちゃいけないんですよ
私たちみたいに質問がありますけど
言ったら十五分も喋ってるんだけど
まだ質問言ってないというね
そういう状態はもうないんですよ
きちんとこの言葉を決めて
こういう質問で形を決めて質問を出すんですね
そうするとこの思考範囲をね
きちんとこの削減して
このガイドラインをつけて
こういう範囲でこの人は質問してるんだっていうことはね
わかるしね だからこの形式的な質問の仕方だと思います
ガッチャンワデーシサマナティトー
ミママンチェブルシッティタンアッティトーティ プッチャーミタンサマナエータマッタン カタンティトウツアンアハンアッティトーミー
ティトアハンアンゴリマーラサンバダサンベスブーテスニダーヤダンダン
トウアンチェパーネスアサンヤトーシータスマーティトウハントウエマッティトーシーという節の良い芸にしているんです
歌としてもすごい綺麗にパーリ語だったらね
大変きれいな作品ですよ
ガッチャンワデーシサマナティトー
ミママンチェブルシッティタンアッティトーティ プッチャーミタンサマナエータマッタン カタンティトウツアンアハンアッティトーミー
ティトアハンアンゴリマーラサンバダサンベスブーテスニダーヤダンダン トウアンチェパーネスアサンヤトーシータスマーティトウハントウエマッティトーシー
ガッチャンワデーシサマナ
サマナよ 歩きながら語るでしょう
ティトアハン 私は止まっている
ママンチェブルシ 私に問うというか
お願いするというか 言うと
やりなさいという言葉なんですね
シッティタンアッティトーと
止まっている私に止まらないと言う
と止まっていないあなたは止まる
止まっているという止まっている私には止まっていないという
それはあなたに誤解いますと
プッチャンタンサマナ
それで質問形 タンサマナプッチャン
これはあなたに聞きますというきちんと形式的な質問を出すんですね
議論を エータマッタン
その解釈 その意味はあなたに質問として出しますと
それでまた質問が出てくるんです
カタンティトウ トワン
あなたはどのようにどういうわけで止まっているというのでしょうか
アハンアッティトーミ
私はどういうわけで止まってないというのでしょうか
それでお釈迦様はティトーアハンアンゴリマーラ
私は止まっている そこで理由は次に何のことの簡単に言う
サッバダー いつでも常にということで
サッバダーっていうのは毎日って意味なんですよ
ですから いつも 常に 毎日
常に いつでも サッベスブーテス
すべての生命に対して
すべての一切の生命に対してニダーエダンダン
ダンダンというのは武器のことで
私はニダーエ 下ろしてますと
あらゆる一切の生命に対して
私は武器というものはもう下ろしている
手放している 何も道具も持てない
石一個でもということで
だから私は止まっていると
行動しないんだから 生命に関わって
あらゆる そういう何も行動しない
もう生命に害を与えるということはもう一切止まる
やめている だから武器は下ろしたということは
大変パーリ語でニダーエダンダンというのは大変なことわざなんですね
ですので よくよくよく出てくることで武器を下ろしましたと
それはもう一切生命を殺さないという意味なんです
トゥアンチャパーネスアサンヤトーティ
トゥアン あなたはパーネス
生き物に対してはアサンヤトー
何の道徳もコントロールも制御もないんだと
君には生命に対して何の管理も
何の道徳も 何の制御も
何一つもない アサンヤっていうのは出来が悪いという
コントロールしていないっていう意味なんですね
タスマー だから故にティトアハン
私は止まっている トゥアンアッティト
あなたは止まってない
ですから この止まるということで
ちょっと言葉の遊びであって
この実際歩くことで止まるということなんですけど
お釈迦様はそれは行動と止まりっていうことにするんですよ
行動と停止という風に使うんですね
それはパーリ語だったら
もう何かやり続けることにもガッチャン
行くという言葉を使ってます
例えばそれは日本語でもそんなにおかしく
勉強していきますとか何とか言えば
勉強してどこかに行くという意味ではなくて
勉強し続けますという意味に解釈はできると思いますけど
どうかわかりませんだけど
ですから 何かの努力 例えば努力していきますと
言えば これからじゃ努力し続けますという意味で
ですから 行きますということは
別に足を動かしているんだというふうな意味だけではないんだと思います
パーリ語になってくると
大体ガッチャティっていうのは何かやり続けるということなんですね
ですからもう行動ですよ
だからやり続ける その行動をお釈迦様はきちんともうストップしたんですね
そこでガッチャとティッタという言葉はもう合わせているんですね
だからお釈迦様はもう生命に対して害を与えるという行動は完全にストップしていて
もうアンゴリマーラがもうもう完璧にそれをやっているんですね
人間見たら殺す もう無差別に殺す
もうあまりにももう極端ですね
二人は 普通の人も生命は人やら殺したりするんだけど
無差別というわけじゃないんですね
わけがあって殺すんであって
どうしても選別はする
誰を殺し 誰を残すかということ
アンゴリマーラにはそれももうなかったんですね
とにかく殺すということでした
で 不思議なことで それだけでアンゴリマーラ真理をわかるんですよ
だからそちら辺で その二人でどういうやりとりあったかっていうことは記録してないんですし
ただポイントだけあって
そのポイントはどう分析するかってことは
これ大変な作業になる
わからない誰でも で これは二人だけのからくりでしたから
お釈迦様は報告しないと誰も知らないし
ですからお釈迦様はただこういう出来事があって
こいつはこういう質問して
私はこういうふうに答えましたよとというだけのことで
それでもう納得してもう帰ったと
本人が ということ それだけ
いわゆる要点だけお釈迦様教えるんですから
こちら側の要点だけで
とにかく だからちょっと仏教の世界ではね
それすごいブッダにしかできない不思議な話やとか何とか言うかもしれませんだけど
もしかするとそれなりに説明した可能性もあるし
またかえってアンゴリマーラっていうのは人を殺したくてこのことをやったわけでもないんですよ
だから殺人者ということは言えるかという問題もあります
人を殺して人を憎しんで
精神的な病気でやったわけじゃないんです
もう頭はその当時になってくると
もうかなりイカれてはいたんだけど
だからといって本人が精神的にイカれた人ではありませんしね
だから注釈書でも まあこの先生がね
人を殺せていたらもう嫌やと
断るでしょうし それで先生はまあそんな先生のちゃんとお礼しなきゃね
学問が身につきませんよと脅しちゃうでしょうね
これが命だからね ブラマン人にとっては学問は
だから自殺と同じことなんですよ
学問身につかないと言っちゃうと
それでもうやむをえずやらなくちゃいけないことになってしまったんですね
ですから 彼にとってはまあ
お釈迦様が私はもう止まってますよと
もう終わってるんだよ
だからすごく安らぎを感じたでしょう
だからこのものすごい苦労して受験勉強して
受験勉強して 苦しんで苦しんで
浪人までやっていて そこら辺でまあ私だったら私は一応合格していますよとかなんとか言うと
なんとなく羨ましいとかね
という気持ちにはなりますし
自分も早くも合格して
こんなもうきつい地獄の受験勉強なんかはやめたいという気持ちにはなるでしょうね
ですから そこら辺で私はもう全部止まってますと
行動はもうやめてますということで
すごい安らぎを初めて感じちゃうんですね
で それからのこの偈自体がかなり古くて
経典よりもこの偈がすごい古いんですよ
それでこの意味がわからないところっていうのはあります
それはまあ 日本ではどうか分かりませんだけど
いろいろ研究していてはっきりしないところいろいろあります
だからこの遠い昔からもうちょっと一言葉がありまして
意味がこの崩れちゃったんですね
だからパーリテキストを見てみると
この 100ページの下
このたくさん このvariant readings というあらゆるテキストにこういう風にあります
この風にあります こんな風にありますとかね
このたった一人の一言葉なんですけど
このほんのかすかに言葉変えると意味も変える
変って変わってしまう
それでも納得いかないです
意味は チラッサンワタメマヒトーマヘシーマハワナングサマノーヤンパッチャワディーソーハンチラッサーパハッサンパパンすつわぬガタンタワダンマユタンタンチラ
ッサンワタメマヒトーマヘシーマハワナングサマノーヤンパッチャワディーソーハンチラッサーパハッサンパー
パンすんわね ガタンタワダンマユタン
そこでこのチラッサンというところは
まあミャンマー版でしょう
おそらくこのチーラッサンにしていますね
そこはそんなにも問題ないんですけど
まあチーラッサン で ワタメマヒとマヒーシーにもまたマヒーシーにして
それはあのメーターのことで
それはメーターは計算してみればどちら正しいかってことは出てきます
で 意味はそんなに危険じゃないんです
マハワナンサマサマノーヤンパッチャワーディーということは大変な疑問なんですよ
これ 3番目なんですけど
ミャンマー版でパープニサッチャワーディー
サマノーヤンということはパープニサッチャワーディーにしているんですよ
で スリランカのテキストでマハワナンサマナンパッチューパーディーにしているんですね
サマノーヤンということもないんで
だからサマノーヤンどちらから取ったんですかね
そこでそのシンハラテキストにスリランカテキストに注釈があって
注釈がサマノーヤンということで
それは注釈は英語の版に使ってるんですね
で サンスクリットのテキストもあるみたいし
そちらはマハワナ これはサマノじゃない
シャムノシュラマノでなきゃ
これ書き方どうかな サンスクリットじゃないと思いますけど
マハワナサマノーヤンパッチュパーディ
サンスクリットじゃないと思いますけどね
サンスクリットだったらマハワナシュラマノーヤンパッチュパーディになりますけどね
また他のテキストでパッチャワーディーという言葉もありますし
パティパッジということにも変えているんですね
これかなり難しいんですね
そのその読み方によって意味が変わってしまっちゃうんです
こちらにはちょっとした厚い論文一つはありますけどね
お読みになるんだったらコピーしてあげます
私は説明はしません で
まあチラッサンというのは
一応普通の英訳から言うと
チラッサン久しぶりですよという
ワタメ まあ自分に対しては久しぶりですと
マヒトマヘマヒーシー
マヒトーというのは偉大なる尊敬に値するというザグレートという意味で
マヒーシーっていうのは大善人ですね
だから久しぶりですね
尊敬に値すべき偉大なる先生に会ったのはと
いわゆる久しぶりに大師に会いましたと
そこでマハワナンサマノーヤン
アヤン様のこの沙門がマハワナも大大きな森ですからね
マハワナというともうかなりのもう森ですよもう
で パッチャワーディーっていうのだったら
この流れで簡単な訳は久しぶりに大先生に会いました
この沙門がこの大きな巨大なこの森に来ていただきましたという意味になってくるなっちゃうんですよ
その場合はパッチューパーディーなんですよ
来ていただきましたっていうのは
この時は パッチャワーディーという言葉では成り立たないんですね
サカソンが大先生がこの森にいらっしゃい
現れましたと来てくれたという場合は
パーリ語だったら まあパッチューパーディーという中にある言葉にはなります
だからその意味正しいかわからないんですよ
それで英語のテキストでパッチャワーディーとありますから
パッチャワーディーっていうのはもう反論者って意味なんですよ
だから反論者っていうのは否定形の意味ではなくって
もう自分 人の考え方やら教え方やら片っ端からこれもう壊して本当のことを見せるという意味なんですね
もう腹立たないと もう真理語ってるんだから
こちら何言ってももうすぐそれはもう壊れてしまうという
だから偉大なる まあ何でしたっけ
論論する人というかね
偉大なる論説者現れたと
パッチャワーディーだったらねになるんですね
そこでこのミャンマー版でパッチャワーディーじゃなくてサッチャワーディーにしているんです
それものすごい簡単なんです
サッチャワーディー 真理を語る大神沙門が森に現れたと
流れから言えば このサッチャという言葉とアングリマーラ引っかかったから嘘言ってるんではない
シャモンたちは嘘言わないんだよと
これが何かあるぞと 嘘はではない
嘘を言うはずがない これが何かある
聞いてみなきゃ ということは流れだから
マハーシャマンに対してはサッチャワーディー形容詞はまあストーリーの流れから見ると
それは一応ピッタシ成り立つんですね
パッチューワーディーパッチャワーディーよりはパッチャワーディーっていうのは徹底的にもう論説をして
もう相手の論理はもう間違っていると示して事実を語ることだから
で そこまで言ってるかどうかまたわからない
そこでまた他の意訳がありまして
おそらく注釈書はパッチャワーディーに取っているでしょう
だからこちらで 注釈書もパッチャワーディーにしていますね
じゃない 注釈書 これとテキストでアングリマーラ
これやっぱりパッチャワーディーですね
注釈書はパティパッチ来ましたという
来ていらっしゃいましたと
という意味で取ってますよ
だからなんでパッチャワーディーはパティパッチになるかっていうとね
まあどうかわからない
とにかく 次にソーハンチラッサーパハッサンパーパンすっとなガタンタワダンマユッタン
まあチラッサー まあそれもすごい訳は難しいんです
意味はまあ私はソーアハン
そういう私がそれで長い間やってきた
このパーパン罪をパハッサンもう捨ててしまったと
理由はスッターナ聞いてガータンタワダンマユッタンタワあなたのガータンあなたの芸を歌を聴いてダンマユッタン法ダンマでダンマが入っていた真理が入っていたあなたの
詩を聴いて
私は長い間やってきた罪をもうやめてしまったと
自分も イッウェーワチョーローアシンアーウダンチェソッベーパパーテーナラキーアンワカーリーアワンディチョーローシュガタッサパーデータテーベナンパッバッ
ジャンアヤーチーブッドーチャコーカーウニコマヘーシーヨーサッサーローカッササデーワカッサタメーヒビックーティタダーオーチェエーセーワタッサーフビックーバーオーティ
とにかくこの出来事は後で歌にしているんですよ
だから歌のそういう作品自体はもう作品なんですよ
出来事があって だから実際にその二人が芸でやりとりやったわけじゃないと思いますけど
あまりにも大胆な出来事だから
その出来事の一番肝心なところを短く芸にしているんです
ですから その芸自体はもう決して後者のものじゃなく
かなり古いものなんですね
アングリマーラ経は経典として構成される以前
芸はあった できた偈はみんなの口くちさんささんでいた偈としてあったものなんです
それをアングリマーラ経典は構成すると入れたということで
アングリマーラ経典自体はまあただのストーリーですよ
別にそんなに教えなんかはね
あるっていうことじゃないんで
一つのストーリーですよ
そこでそのチラッサンワタメマヒトマヘーシという
このすごいかっこいいこの偈で疑問いくつか出てくるんで
チラッサン久しぶりということはどういう意味かと
このエピソードの中で
アングリマーラにとっては
何でお釈迦様は久しぶりになるんですかね
これすごく怪しいんですよ
で なんでアングリマーラは沙門たちがものすごい厳密な真理を語る
偽りは絶対言わない生き方をしているんだよと
なぜそこら辺はしっかりして知ってるんでしょうかとね
もう解決してないんです
そういう問題は 久しぶりと言えるんですかね
殺そうとしていたんだから
ですから このチラッサンワタメマヒトマヘーシということはすごくわかりにくいんですよ
この何でしたっけ？じっすに久しくと言うんですか
じつに  久しく尊敬された
尊敬された真理を語る大聖は私のために大輪に来たもう
来たもうという このじっすに久しくっていうのはわからないんです
だから前もってね 何か関わりがないと言えるものじゃないでしょうに
ブッダの言葉を聞いて
私はもうやめましたっていうのは
それはそんなに珍しいことじゃないんですけど
チラッサンという一言葉
すごい引っかかる言葉なんですね
それは一つの疑問点で
次の偈に行きます イティエーワチョーローアシンアウダンチャ
イティエーワ これからチョーローこの泥棒がこの犯人
何でした？今日今日即今日即ですね
そうですね まあ一応自分持っていろいろ武器を持ってましたから
全部捨ててしまったんですね
崖に捨ててしまったんですね
だからそういう険しいところでしたからね
断崖あったり いろんなもう崖があったり
倉庫あったりとかね そこら辺であの日のアンリマーラは後ろから攻撃する戦術でしたから
あっちこっち隠れて隠れて走って走ってくるんですけど
お釈迦様は何のことなく短い道で歩いて
それで違いがなかった可能性もありますけどね
それは全部捨ててしまったと
それからアワンディチョーローシュガタッサパーデ
この教則が釈尊の足を足に礼をしましたと
それでタテーワナンパッバジャンアヤージ
全部あれを捨てて お釈迦様の足に礼をして出家を願うんですね
そこでお釈迦様も何のことなく
もうもう教則なのに やっぱりブッドーチャコーカーニコーマヘーシー
ブッダっていうのはまことに憐れみ深く
偉大なる仙人 マヘーシーっていうのは偉大なる仙人であって
サッチャーローカッササデーヴァカッサ
誰にでも先生だよと 神々であろうと人間であろうと
ブッダは先生だから もうだからお釈迦様を守ってあげてるんです
その偈の中でお釈迦様にとってはどうすることもない
相手が泥棒や人殺しやとかね
言ったとしても 自分がその人の先生だから
人類の先生だから だから優しくしてあげるのはブッダの仕事なんですよ
もう叱回事するとかね
あんたもう犯罪だらけだから出ていけとかね
そういうことはできないんだと
ブッダには ブッダは偉大なる仙人で
もう大憐れみを持っていて
それはいいんだけど それ一番まずいところはもう人間
神々の先生なんですよ
だからこの先生という立場は大変なきつい立場なんですね
とにかく育ててあげなくちゃいけないんですね
たとえ弟子がもうどんなことをしたって
悪いことをやったっても
先生は優しく なんとかしてなんとかして育ててあげなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 本当はお釈迦様はこの人に出家させたことは良くないんですよ
これほど人殺してるのに
一般人の感情っていうのはどう考えるんだ
人を馬鹿にしているんですかと
これほど人殺してるのにという
と言われるのは当たり前なんですけど
だからってブッダどうすればいいんですかね
お釈迦様にとってはもう人類誰でも自分が育ててあげなくちゃいけない
もう弟子たちなんですよ
神々 人類 すべての人々に現れた唯一の先生だから
それは見逃すわけにはいきませんでしょう
一人の人でも ということで
一応お釈迦様の立場を守っているんです
そちらで この偈で そういうわけで
エーヒビクでただをじゃあいいですよと
お釈迦様が出家させる言葉っていうのは
来たる比丘ってその二言葉なんですよ
エーヒビク その二言葉を釈迦様は口から出たら
その前にいた人が完全な一人前の出家なんです
何も儀式は行いません
普通だったら出家するともうすごく儀式があります
その儀式の段取りをちゃんといて
一人前の比丘になるんです
それはそう簡単ではありませんし
時間かかるし ちゃんと責任を持つ先生がいなくちゃいけないし
教師という人がいなくちゃいけないし
大体先生三人ぐらい作るんだからに
そういう人々のところで修行して
ちゃんと証明をもらって
この人はできているんだと
信頼できるんだと その先生たちが報告しないと
比丘たちサンガに そこでもうその先生たちがサンガを集めてくれなきゃ
また自分にはできません
出家する人には そこで出家する人が自分の願いを立てる
願いを立てたら その時報告するときは
この先生たちの名前 私はこういう先生の弟子であると
この先生は教師であって
この先生はなんとアシャリであるとかね
そのアシャリとこのウパッジャヤのところで私は出家しますのでお願いしますということで
そこでサンガが先生たちを信頼するんだから
その先生たちの信頼のもとで出家を認めるという儀式ですよ
それにはもうそれそれ時間かかりますし
出家したっても年経つまでは一人前になるということはないしね
そういう普通なんで お釈迦様は何一つもない
たった二言葉で エーヒビク
それで比丘なんです お釈迦様に言われた人は年間の見習い人は何一つもない
一言葉で全て終了という
だから出家の一番最高な出家なんです
ブッダに直々出家してくれるんだから
でお釈迦様は本師だからね
お釈迦様の勝手でしょう
何であろうともね ですから
それはそういうことで
だからお釈迦様に認めたら
もう誰にもそれは断れないでしょうに
お釈迦様反抗してるんだから
サンガ集めて あんたはそれほど立派な比丘には認めたくないとか言えますかね
どうにもならんですよ
ですから ものすごい力強い立場が強いんですよ
ブッダに直々出家を認めた人々
だからでもみんな阿羅漢なんですね
普通の人にはやってあげないんです
で お釈迦様直々認めるのは
もう出家する前にも阿羅漢になる場合もありますよ
サイケデで話聞いて そこでもう阿羅漢になってしまう
悟ってしまうと それでも家に戻りません
だからそういう人々はね
では出家をお願いしますと
まあいいやということで
それは悪い まあいいんじゃないかと
エイヒビクク まあいいよ
いらっしゃいと 比丘としていらっしゃいと
いわゆるこのグループに入りなさいと
エイヒっていうのは入会
入会というかね 入団評価しますということなんですね
比丘として入団評価しますと
それでお釈迦様はエイヒビククで
ただをその時エイヒビククと言って言いましたと
エイセイはタッサアホビクバオ
それがそれだけで彼が比丘になってしまったと
だから寸時の出来事というかね
もう大泥棒がもう零点一秒でもう完全な比丘ということになるんだからね
で おそらくこの色んなこの仏教の活動っていうのは
もうこのスケールの広さっていうのはね
これはもう日本では理解できないと思いますけど
この思考はもう広大でね
仏教活動というのはすごい思考的にはすごい広大なんですね
だからこの学者たちが言うのは
まあインドでなかなかこの文化的な社会に
このインテリ社会にもう入れないというか
えらい悪い奴らがいたんですよ
この犯罪者ではないんだけど
特にこのカーリーという女神
ヤシにですけどね いわゆる悪霊というかね
まあ信仰する今もありますけど
すごい伝統なんですよ
ある女の女神というか
このカーリー名前はカーリーですけどね
で 信仰して信仰はすごく強いんですね
それは民間的に厳密にある
今もある だからカーリー女神がの乗り物はジャガーなんですよ
結構高級車なんですよ
だからインドに行くと
このこのトラックやらね
そういう人々をね 普通の労働者
車にボーンと大きく書いてるんですね
もう虎のジャガーの絵をね
描いて カーリーの女神に挨拶するサンスクリット語でその文句を書いてあるんですよ
だから彼女に守られて頑張りますということで
だから車は普通のインド製のトラックかもしれませんだけど
ジャガーのマークが入っていると
それはジャガーの会社のものというわけではなくて
カーリー神様を信仰している人やということになるんです
そこでこの彼女の仏像とは言わないね
まあ造形作ってますから
もう子供の首とかもこうやって手で持ってるんですね
だから血がボロボロと切ったままで切って
すぐもうそれで手で持ってるんですね
で 口にも子供は横にしてくわえてるんですよ
子供か人間かわからない
とにかく まあ人相 まあだから造形学的にプロポーション小さくしなくちゃあかんでしょ
いくらなんでも だからいくら顔を大きく広げて作ったっても
体より顔を大きくすることはできませんだから
だからまあ口にはめてますよ
人間一人ぐらい 手でも持っているし
またいろいろ武器を持っていて
かなり徹底的に恐ろしい形に作ってるんですね
で 動物は未だに殺してあげるんですよ
その神に ずっとやってます
だからこの生贄ですよ
だからもうカーリー女神には生贄をする
できればありがたいと
一番いいお供えになるんだと
だからジャータカ物語やら
このいろんなジャータカじゃなくダンマパダ物語でも
時々森の中でお坊さん捕まって殺されるようになったとか
いくつか出てくるエピソードは出てくるんですね
だから神に差し上げることにしましたよと
だから そういう泥棒やら
そういうクラスの人々はもう必ず信仰する
だから そういう連中が広げると
社会的にもすごい不安定で平和がなくなる
だから大泥棒のグループは人を殺して神様に差し上げちゃうと
それで神様に守ってくれると
これ困ったもんなんですよ
だからカーリー神を否定することはインド人にとってはできないんですね
インド人はもうあらゆる神様を信仰しているんだから
いないとは思わないし
でもこれ人食ってありがたく喜ぶ神だから
これ困るんですね だから神にお供えしたりお願いしたりすると
神と人間のコンタクトが成り立って問題が起こるんだから
別に誰もお供えも何もしないで無視してしまえば
自分を守るために別な神
別の神やら他の神を選べばいいでしょうに
だからもう文化の人々はもう太陽かもうラーマか何か他の猿か
もうもうどちらで牛かね
もう誰かを信仰して だから牛を信仰してるでしょ
牛は梵天の車ですよ だから牛を尊敬するようになってしまってるんですね
向こうでも だからそれは一般人が牛なんですけど
ある特定の人々はやっぱり虎なんですね
とかでしょうかね ヴィャーグリーだからね
ヒョウじゃないね ヴィャーグリーはおそらく虎でしょうからな
だからこれがこのヒンドゥー教の人々には
この問題解決することはまずできない
仏教は至る宗教にも一応入っちゃうんです
浸透するんですよ あらゆる文化に浸透する
あらゆる宗教に浸透する
浸透して この間違いを直して
文化的な それそのまま仏教にするか
文化的な宗教に改良するか
どちらかにするんですよ
ジャイナ教にしたっても
ジャイナ教は仏教に浸透したところいっぱいありますけど
もう仏教もとことんジャイナ教を浸透して
恐ろしい苦行はやめてもらったんですよ
それでみんなにありがたがるぐらいのレベルの苦行で今ストップしているんです
でないと もう全く裸で行者たちが徹底的に苦行しているんですよ
そこで断食して死ぬことはものすごく最高な苦行にしていて
そういうことを広げちゃうと
人間何やるかというと
もう商売とかうまくいかない
じゃあだったら修行して悟りを見るぞと思って
それで断食すればそれで終わりだから
もう簡単だから だからそうやって簡単に修行して成功したんだと
商売やら家政環境はちょっとうまくいかなかったんだけど
その人を出家して もうそれで一人前の行者になったぞということになってくると
それはもうちょっと常識的に考えるとおかしくて困るんですよ
ブッダはそれを壊すんですよ
食わないで死んじゃっても何のこともないやと
ただ食わないで死んだだけやということで知って
そこはけなしちゃうんですね
だったら何が行者よ それはもう欲がない
怒りのない心を育てることだというふうに言ってしまうと
ジャイナ教ももうしょうがないということで
そこら辺はどんどんどんどんカットするんですよ
だから お釈迦様がジャイナ教に浸透したことのおかげで
ジャイナ教は未だにすごい品格のある宗教としてインドで生き残っているんですよ
ヒンドゥー教も生き残っているのは仏教のおかげなんですよ
仏教が浸透してはいろんなところを壊しておかない限りはもうもう壊れちゃいますよ
全くもう下品ももう品のないもいいところだから
ではそちらに修行やら瞑想やら
あらゆることをもうカースト制度は難題とかね
そこはとか もういろんなことを壊して壊して壊して
もうただバラモンで生まれたんだけど
ただの人間ではないかとかね
バラモン人の社会立場も壊しちゃったりして
で この人を差別することも
人を搾取することもできるだけもう壊したんですよ
それで壊したって仏教は慈悲の教えだから
決して悪いことはしない
これはもうちょっと痛いんだけど
手術なんですよ 痛いんですけど
手術しちゃうんですね
だから一旦手術終わったら元の形にはならないんですよ
だからで別児になったわけではないんです
それでよかったと だから仏教のこの広大さというのはそこら辺にすごくあるんですね
いとも簡単に他種仏教であろうか
どんな思想体系であろうか
すぐ侵食する それに入る
入ってただではならない
いろんなところを壊す
壊して何か別な形に成り立っちゃうんです
そうすると だから完全に潰してしまうということは
もう全然そんな興味ないんです
どうせ人間やってることだから
まあまあ勝手にやれと
でも迷惑かけらないと
人類にだけ迷惑をかけらないよと
生命には迷惑がかからないよと
あなた方にとって幸せだったら
その分はもうどうぞやってくださいと
でも あなた方の幸せのために誰にでも迷惑をかけちゃうと
ただでは済まないんだと
そこら辺は攻撃する だからこの完全に仏教になってくると
すごいインテリ的で もうもう驚くほどの社会的な立場が出てる
だからお釈迦様の時代で
仏教では仏教徒といえばもう認められる人
信頼できる人ということになっているんですよ
だからシャマのサッキプッティアというのも大変な立場なんですよ
釈迦の息子たちと言われるのは
もうだったらもうインテリ中インテリで
もう完璧に信頼できる人々だと
で 人の宗教 何とか何とかという
それうるさくはないし
仏教徒になるかならないかいうと自由だからね
そこら辺でもすごく柔軟性を持っている
強引に人を仏教徒にしようしようと全然しません
強引にさせたっても もう何の意味もないんだからね
強引にはしないんだけど
相手の間違いは壊しちゃいます
それはどんな教えの中にも入ることできるんだから
いとも簡単に 入ってしまって間違いは壊して
それでもう帰っちゃうんですね
間違いを壊しちゃったら
向こうは向こう 前の形ではもう成り立たない
もう壊されちゃったんだから
それから残り分でなんとかシステム体系を作らなくちゃいけない
そのシステム体系はそれほど人類に迷惑ということではなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうふうな 頑張ってきたんですよ
そこでいくつかのところに見えてくるのは
このカーリー信仰にも攻撃してやろうではないかという企みというかね
これももう壊しておかないとあかんと
カーリーを信仰するのは勝手でいいんですよ
それは僕は別に気にしない
このカーリーにもう人間を生贄に差し上げてもいいやという考え方は
何とかしなくちゃいかない
動物でも生贄にしてあげてもいいやという
これが何とかしなくちゃいかないということで
このカーリー信仰を壊すために
今ちょっとからくりはやっているんですね
これは他の人々には誰にもできない
このカーリーを信仰する人々は
一応もう社会のインテリ社会にこのクラスのね
まあ中級クラスでもにはもう全然関係なく
低級クラスで労働しながら生きている人々で
窃盗やら泥棒やら強盗やら
そういう職業なんですね
だからこの一般の人々はもう関係持たない
バラモン人も心配しない
そういう人々のことは
王様だったら殺してやることぐらいをするんだけど
心配することはしない
だから仏教にとっては
やっぱりこの人々のことをどうしますかと
誰も心配しないんだから
だから仏教にしたって
仏教はもうインドで一番上のクラスの宗教であって
インテリ中のインテリの宗教ですけど
これ心配でたまらないんですね
だからなんとか方法ないかと
この連中にも一つ一言葉言ってやる方法ないかということで
いくつかの努力っていうのは見えてきます
仏典の中では 有名な物語は
このダンパダの第二章で出てくるこの怒りは怒りで治りませんという偈のエピソードなんですね
怒りは怒りで治めることはないと
それは慈しみしかなくならないんだ
これは永遠な真理だと
というところで それはカーリーの信仰者にそのエピソードをつなげているんですね
実際にカーリー信仰者にそれは関係あることわからない
とにかく怒りを強化するんですよ
だから仕返しすること
誰か敵がいるんだったら
敵を殺してくれとカーリー神に頼む
カーリーはもうそれをただではやらなくてやってくれませんだから
お供えしないと それで誰かをもう生贄にしてあげると
生贄してあげちゃうと
もうそれで敵を殺してくれるんだっていうね
それはもう怒りに怒りだから
そんなものでは解決しませんよと
解決するのは慈しみでですよっていう大胆な教えを出しちゃうんですね
誰か 例えば自分の家に泥棒が入って
自分の家の誰かを殺しちゃったならば
家の人々はすごく怒るでしょうね
激怒したところで泥棒誰かわからない
顔を見てない 家に戻ってきたら
家は壊れているし ものは盗まれているし
家にいた人々は殺されているし
そうするとその人々はもうお手上げだから
直行でカーリ女神の神社に行く
行って敵を殺してくれと
殺してくれると まあ山羊 4頭でも5頭でもそれなりに約束してくれるんですよ
生贄に差し上げますと
お礼としてと それで毎日毎日お祈りに行く
だからそれで解決するかと
問題は だからその迷信仏教を認めません
だからこれで毎日行くと
この人々の心の中でも
おそらく犯人はあの人
あの人ではないかという疑いが
雲がかかっちゃうでしょうし
もしそういう人々に何か不幸があったら
やっぱり神様がもう行ってやってくれたということで
まあかわいそうに 山羊 5頭の命がなくなってしまっちゃうというかね
逆にそうやって自分の家族の旦那が死んだのは
あの家族がカーリ神に呪いをかけたんだからとわかったらどうなりますか？そちらも同じ神に呪いをかけるでしょうに
じゃあ 6頭お供えしますと
だからそこはもう人間の社会的な問題に答えではありませんと
許してあげなさいよと
それで終わりと チャラと全部一回で
自分の誰が殺したならば
もう犯人が知っていたっても知らなくたっても
もうそれをもうもう許してあげて
自分の残りの命で もう生計を立てれば
それで損害っていうのは最小限に留まるでしょうに
だから 起きた出来事はもう取り返せませんだからね
死んだ人はもうどうも帰ってこないんだから
だったら損は最小限にする方法をお釈迦様は教えてるんですね
損はもうとっくに起きてることだから
別にどうったことないでしょうにも
ブッダの教え聞いたんだから損しましたってことじゃないんだから
損はもう起きちゃった
もう終わった だったらそれ広げないようにすることでしょうに
そういうことで この怒りは怒りで消えないぜという経があって
それのエピソードはカーリなんですね
カーリ女神のエピソードが出てきて
これ来世物語から出てきて
もう来世かもう過去世物語に出てきて
お互いに殺し合いやって
今度はこちらをあっちを殺す
それで生まれ変わって
向こうはこちらを殺すと
そういうやり取りがあって
もうお釈迦様の時代になってくる
ある女が子供を他のお母さんから子供を奪っちゃって逃げるんですね
そこで女が子供を捨てて逃げるというよりも
これはもうこの子供を殺すつもりだと
だからおそらくカーリに人間を生贄に差し上げるんだとという約束あったかもしれません
自分の子供が病気になって死にかけたところで
もしかすると神に願いを立てちゃって
もし私の子供がもう生き返って元気になったら
あなたに命に命を差し上げますと
言うと約束したんだけど
誰かを自分の子供を殺してあげるわけにはいきませんだからね
それは それであちこち気が弱そうな女の人から平気で子供奪って逃げたでしょうと思いますね
そこでその女がカーリ女神にストーリーをして
その女は本当は人間に変身したカーリ神でしたと
でお釈迦様の前で逃げた
あのお母さんがやっぱり負けなか
とにかく追っていったんですね
子供を返せと それで逃げて逃げて逃げるところじゃなく
で まあお釈迦様がいるところは別にもう森やらいっぱいありますわ
そこでもう入り込んじゃって隠れたって
でもなかなかお釈迦様のところに来られないし
それでお釈迦様は自分のところに来いと呼ばれたら
その子供を持って逃げた女がそちらに来て
それでお母さんもそちらに来て
まあ子供を自分の子供を返せと
そこでお釈迦様は二人にちゃんと説法してね
これがあかんやと もうやりきれんと
あなた方にとっては ということで終わりにしたんですね
その問題は で 最後にそのお母さんにお釈迦様がね
じゃあこの子供 その女にあげなさいと
この殺そうとした女に
お釈迦様の前だからね
何のことなくあげるんですよ
いいです 抱っこしなさい
それでこの殺そうとした女も
やっぱり子供を抱っこして
ちゅうをして可愛がってあげて
じゃあもう元気で育ててくださいとまた返してあげる
そこでも怒り憎しみはないということで
もうこれからはと で 子供を殺したかった女の心にも
どんな子供でも愛する気持ちを作ってあげたんですよ
で それでこのカーリ神が預流果に悟りましたと
カーリという女神が 預流果に悟ったんだから
もうこれからは人を殺して食べることはできません
彼女はもう死んでももう殺生はしないことになったと
そこからは仏教のヒストリーなんですけど
もうカーリ神はそれっきりで
もう自分が死んでも殺生はできないことになってしまったと
預流果に悟ったんだからと
それでカーリ神がいくらなんでも食べ物なくなっちゃったんだからね
悲しい顔をしている それでお釈迦様はあの女の人
お母さんにね あなたはこの女を自分の家に連れてきなさいと
女ではない もう神だから
もう霊だからね この霊を自分の家に連れて行きなさいと
自分の家に連れて行って
毎日お供えして霊をしなさいと
霊というかお供えしなさいと言って
このそれで伝統的な神を信仰するあの文化をまた守ってあげる
それまでは壊さない でも生贄ではなくて
もう家で作っているご飯とか
お水とか果物とか そういう誰にも害のないものを神にお供えしなさいと
それを毎日やってくださいと
ということで 子供を抱っこして
お母さん そのお母さんが家に戻って
それからカーリ神に自分の子供を殺そうとしたカーリ神に毎日お供えをすると
それで仏教は狙ったのはカーリ信仰する人々が生贄はやめてちょうだいと
その代わりに果物ぐらいでいいんじゃないかと
何かお願いするんだったら
ということで この信仰も人類に害のない宗教に変えてみようではないかということで
あの宗教そのものを壊すんですよ
カーリが夜叉で鬼で人を殺すのはもうその霊の特色なんですよ
だからその宗教教えそのものを壊してますよ
それから菜食主義になるんだから
肉食になる これはもうもう虎にご飯食べさせるようなことで
ライオンにもうジャガイモやらキャベツ
人参やらね どんと出してもライオン食わんですけど
仏教はそれやらせるんですね
乗り物でも虎でしょうし
だから肉食べるのは当たり前に他のものは食べられない
なのに仏教はすごい厳密に
それはすごいインテリ的で
この怒りってそれ事実ですから
怒りでは怒りは永久的に消えないんだからね
どんどんどんどん燃えて燃えて損だけ増える
何の得もないことだから
いい加減目覚めすらいいでしょうに
目覚めさえすれば だから目覚めさ
それしてみなさいという話でしょうしね
それでそういうストーリーがありまして
それからは仏教徒もカーリ神が自分の仲間にする
もう悟ってるんだから
もう兄弟ですね そこで仏教徒にも違和感なく
カーリ女神のお堂というか
お参りする霊場なんかには堂々と行ける
仲間です 兄弟です それで何か仏教徒の何か世俗的な困ったことがあったら
もうカーリ神様 ちょっといかがでしょうか
私達のこういう問題があるということでお願いしたって
それはいいですと 別に
やってくれるんだと思う
仲間っていうことで まあそういうことで一時的な心慰めにでもなるし
他宗教と汚い争いもないんでしょ
だから仏教徒にとってはいとも簡単に他宗教の信仰する霊場なんかには出入りできるようにしているんですね
でも今は禁止されてますけど
イスラム教なんかも入れてくれないんですけど
キリスト教も入れてくれないというね
悪魔の連中や だから代わりに仏教はみんなにいつでも来てくださいと
今ない 寺に入ろうと思ったら
あんた何宗教？全然聞きませんだから
その代わりにこの品のないことだけやめなさいという
西洋の女が来たっても
ちゃんと体隠せと 厳しい
帽子脱げなさいと 帽子を脱げて裸ですからね
みんなそういう文化発達しているんだからね
それはやめさせる ですから
よくヨーロッパの観光グループたくさん来るんですけど
みんな寺に入る前にちょっと腰に何か布一つつまいて
靴とか全部脱いで 帽子なんか全部預かり所で預かってもらって歩くんですよ
足で そこで靴脱いだんだからって絨毯それをわざとしません
靴脱いだところでお客さんに絨毯の上で行って本堂に入るようにとはしません
そこら辺 普通の砂利道やら砂やら
それは普通にしておくんです
歩いてきて それだけのことですけど
それはみんな嫌がりますけど
それは変えません 時と場合しも
そこら辺ちょっと石の何とかでもして置いたっていいやと
その方がいいと 汚れた方が
なんだそんな高慢っていう
という風にまあしてあって
たとえ暑くても 外の仏塔なんかだったら
昼の間 特にアンラートブルポーっていうのはすごいすごい暑いんですよ
仏塔の前では石段で全部床作ってますよ
太陽が来るともう西洋人どころか私たちにも行けません
もう朝早く行くんです
朝早くで一生懸命起き上げて
サッと 昼なんか行かない
で 観光で行ったら昼で時間関係ないんだから
これは認めません 歩いてきて
靴脱ぎなさいと 立ち入り禁止とは言わないんです
礼をしたければ礼をしてもいい
礼をしたくなければ見学して帰ったって
それは全然気にしない
だから この柔軟性と自由っていうことは
仏教は未だに守ってますけどね
だから仏教は他の人連中もそんなことやりなさいよと
どんな教会に誰が来たってもいいんじゃないかと
何だと この秘密主義っていうのは
それがいけないんだと
日本の場合にしても 宗教組織といえば極力秘密主義
閉鎖主義で 言いながらまたずっと信者獲得にあらゆる悪徳商法
何であろうと何でも使うという
ちょっと自由に透明にしてしまえばどうですかね
何一つも透明にしないでしょうに
それももうすごいけしからんなね
もう 現代的でもないし
インテリ的でもないし
人間らしくもないやり方なんですよ
昔から仏教はそこら辺ではすごい考えているところで
いろんな工夫するんですよ
この相手の宗教システムを壊すためには
この壊すということは
世間にある宗教対立と全くやり方が違う
これは手術的な感覚で壊すんです
仏教は壊してるんじゃなくて手術してるだけ
手術してる医者だけ 相手はもういいんで
犬であろうが猫であろうが人間であろうが
もう病気やじゃあいいや
分かります もう切って何とか治してあげるぞということで
悪いところは切って捨てちゃう
だからとにかく手術なんです
切っては捨てる いろんなところ
そこでもう病気治したっても
完璧に元の体に戻るわけはないんです
もう手術したんだからね
でもそれそれからのできた体の方が前よりはいいと
病気のままでがんがあったままでいるよりは
一部と一緒にがんを捨てた方がいいでしょうに
いろいろ不自由なところいくらあっても
それでその人の命は守られますから
ですから この他宗教を壊すと言ったっても
その壊し方っていうのはもう手術的な壊し方なんですね
だから完全に全滅させようということはしない
だからこのカーリ女神の物語の中でも
カーリの神を信仰する文化的な伝統をそのまま生き続けるようにとついておくんですね
だからもうカーリ信仰を捨てている人々だけではなくて
仏教徒でもどうぞ行ってくださいと
そうするともっと仲良くなるんだよと
仏教徒までそこに行けるようにしてしまう
そうすると相手の宗教も自分が負けた
損したという怒りがないでしょうね
かえって信者さんが増えただけだから
ある面で そうすると仏教の人々も来ると
みんなの気持ち考えて活動しなくちゃいけないことにもなるし
そういう風にこの とにかく人類に平和的に何とかしてあげようというね
ことでは頑張っているんですけどね
そういうわけなんですけど
まあ同じわけで 仏教は日本に不調和しない宗教にもなってますけど
だからこのアングリマーラのエピソードは
まあそういうエピソードもカーリのね
絡んでるんじゃないかなという考え方もあります
伝統的な考え方ではないんですけど
それは学者たちの研究結果
研究的な思考ですけどね
で この日本になってくると
鬼子母神という信仰がありますね
あれはカーリなんですね
子供を守る神に 子供を殺す神を子供を守る神に入れ替えると
で テーラワーダ仏教では一応そういう話はあるんだけど
誰もカーリ神を信仰してないんです
から 公道の大乗仏教になってくると
まあすごい真面目に信仰すると
テーラワーダの人々はもう裏わかってるんだからね
何やったかと だからそれほどもう全然知らない
もう今のテーラワーダの人々に聞いても
カーリ神と もうそう あれは仏教じゃないって
大乗になってくると やっぱりそういう迷信はもうありがたがる世界だから
まあ大事な菩薩一人というかね
まあ神一人になってはいますけど
決して悪いことではないんですけど
とにかくそういうエピソードはね
インドで起きた出来事だから
この一応カーリ信仰と仏教の対立はあったことは確かですからね
そこで仏教はある答え出しましたからね
ですから 全く非仏教的な信仰というわけではないんだけど
一生懸命神を信仰して子供を守ってくれと
自分で守ればいいのにね
自分の子供ぐらい自分で守ればいいっていうのがテーラワーダの立場に
で その代わりに自分 国によって信仰が変わりますから
ミャンマーの人の信仰
タイの スリランカの人の信仰っていうのは国によって変わりますよ
いろいろ土着宗教 土着信仰いっぱいありますからね
ミャンマーでもいろんな霊やらいろんなものを信仰するんですね
だからそれは仏教と合体しているし
タイになってくると中国の思想までいろいろ入っちゃっているし
それは仏教と合体していますよ
スリランカになってくると
もうインドは近いんだから
インド ヒンドゥー文化はものすごい壁を作ってますね
はっきりと明確に壁を作ってるんです
壁を作っても 巨大な文化っていうのは当然漏れるし
我々のスリランカ文化っていうのは
いくらスリランカ人が威張ったっても
インド インド文化の一部だから
これはもうすっごい威張ってはいるんですよ
まるっきり違うと 威張るのはいいんだけど
実際はまあインド文化の一部であることは明確な事実でしょうし
そこで壁一つは仏教の壁なんですね
仏教だったら認めると
何でも インドのものはどうぞいらっしゃいと
仏教だろうならばというきつい壁を作る
でもヒンドゥー教の影響もどうせ入っちゃいますね
それでしたらどうしようもないと
もうヒンドゥーの偉い神々はみんな仏教徒にしてしまっちゃって
強引に じゃあどうぞどうぞ
そこらそこら辺にいてくださいと
もう一応 一応入れておくんですね
それで一応平和的な 何と言いますか
トレランスというかね
寛容的な環境 対立をやめてもらうんですね
だから 何のことなくスリランカのお寺に行ったら
ヒンドゥーの神々がいるんです
それは我々と全然何の違和感も何もない
どうぞどうぞと神様を
ことにしている だから好きな人はその神様に何かお願いする
それは全然誰も嫌と思わない
全然お願いしたくない人はお釈迦様に礼をしてお花を差し上げて
そのまま帰っちゃうと
でも 神様だけ目指して神様に何かお供え物をしてそのまま帰る人は批判する
これであんた不幸になるんだよ
それよくないと 神の恵みくれるところじゃなくて
逆になるんだぜ お釈迦様侮辱するんじゃないと
どうせ元仏教徒だからね
ですから 順番がありまして
まずお釈迦様へ礼をして
お供えをして 花やら水やら差し上げて
御開を受けてお経をあげたり
いろんなことをして それからついでに神様に実はこういうお願いなんですけど
いかがでしょうかと という順番なんですね
だからこの そうやってヒンドゥーの神々何人かがスリランカ人人気ある神々何人かが入ってますが
梵天はあまり入りません
即即の神々なんですね
即次元の 梵天には全然お参りしません
で これは分からなかったんですね
タイに行ったらなるほどと
タイでは梵天にもやっているところに
明らかにヒンドゥー的な多宗教的な色付けがすごい強いんですね
ああ なるほど だからスリランカ人に嫌われてるんだって
そこでタイで梵天の神々の信仰する宗教に行ったところで
スリランカ人にヒンドゥー教の一番上の神は梵天なのに
なんで嫌われているかと
やっぱりお礼をしたりすると
ヒンドゥー教の色付けがなんとなく入ってしまうんですね
それが嫌で だからその代わりにヴィシュヌ神とかは信仰しています
ヴィシュヌ神は宇宙創造してから守る神ですね
シヴァを信仰しません
シヴァは破壊の神で 信仰しない理由は
ヒンドゥー教の色付けっていうのはえらい派手なんですね
破壊の神 欲の神でもある
怒りの神でもある だからシヴァの人相も裸でしょ
踊っているナタラジャというね
ああいうのはもうあんまり信仰にあるんだけど
スリランカでも作った作品とか
信仰対象にはしない 梵天というのは作った神だから
これ仏教的な梵天違うんだけど
一旦ヒンドゥーの梵天神様にもちょっといいやと
いらっしゃいと言ったところで
世界宇宙創造した神になっちゃうんですね
だからお前はいいやと
お前はもういいと で ヴィシュヌはもう生命を管理
維持して守る神でしょうに
まあまあ どうぞどうぞと
ということで もう仏教に近い神だけまあ信仰しているんですね
ですから ヴィシュヌ神の人相っていうのはもう至る所にあります
まあ人を守るねということは
慈しみっていうのは行為だからね
で それでまたヴィシュヌ神は仏教徒にして
ヴィシュヌ神は本当は仏教徒であると
ブッダの弟子であると
それでヴィシュヌ神の神王様が大釈尊だからね
お釈迦様は大釈尊にまあもう命令してあるんだと
仏教徒もちゃんと守れと
言ったっても 大釈尊はあんまりいい加減なことでいい政治家じゃないと
もうすごいもう忘れっぽいで
もうお釈迦様に怒られるんだからね
説法したってもすぐ忘れちゃうということで
もう何回怒られたこともあるしね
そこを知ってるんだから
まああまり当てにならないんだと
王様ですけどね そういうことで
大釈尊が まあこれ大変な命令やと
大変な重大責任やということで
ヴィシュヌ神に仕事をじゃあ君に任せますと
いうことで ヴィシュヌ神がもうどうしてもスリランカの仏教徒や仏教徒を守らなくちゃいけないと
ということで スリランカでどんなお寺でもヴィシュヌの人相があります
だからそれぞれ宗教的な解釈次第だから
仏教徒はそういう解釈で
そんな解釈 ヒンドゥー教の人が聞いたらえらい怒るかもしれませんだけど
それはもう構わず自分たちの解釈で信仰する
で ヒンドゥー教の人が来たら同じ人相だから
じゃあ一緒にお祀りお守りしましょうということで
仲良くお守りはする でもそれぞれの解釈は違う
そこはまあ宗教の共存の技ですよ
対立にはならないように
それぞれ自分の解釈を持ってるだけで
仏教徒がヴィシュヌ神を尊敬しているのを見たら
もう全く同じようと全く違いますね
やり方は でもヒンドゥー教の人には嫌とは言えないしね
だからシヴァの神の代わりにスリランカで現れた別の神がいるんです
それからこのカーリーの神はないんですけど
その代わりにもうこのスリランカ人が昔からアリー人の先駆の以前からも
あの遠いこの文化以前からも守って信仰していた女の神がいるんですよ
で その神に委託しているんです
子供を守ることは で なんとかという神ですね
で 神名前ないんですよ
結局ハートインですよ
名前もないんです で パッチンという名前なんですけど
パッティネっていうのはどんな意味かわからない
これシンハラ語だからね
おそらくパティニーだと思いますよ
まあお子さんというかね
まあご婦人というね という名前だと思いますけど
これで次に母っていう名前をつけてるんですね
もうどこでどうやって何者かわからない
とにかく スリランカ文化にはいる
とにかくどこにでも で
インドから外来だったらもう全部歴史はありますけど
これはもう土着のものだから
もう誰もわからない いろんなストーリー
エピソードはあるんだけど
一つも全部民間のエピソードで
それほど研究されるようになりません
だから 子供に何か問題があったり
病気にかかったり 不幸になったりすると
さっさとじゃあお母さんに頼みますということで
そのお母さんってその神のことで
そこで頼んでおく すごい簡単です
お母さんだから ややこしいことしなくてもいいんです
全ての子供のお母さんだから
もう色々お供えしてくれなきゃ
やってやらないと それありえませんだからね
ちょっと頼んだだけで十分です
すごい便利 実はお母さんも困っているんだと
子供がもう病気でということで
で まあまあ大体子供っていうのは病気になっても治りますから
治ったらそれなりに礼をしますね
そのお母さん神にそういう礼のやり方っていうのは
またなんだすごい簡単で
そこら辺にいる普通のお母さん
人呼ぶんで 自分の家に
誰でもいいんですよ まあ大体お母さん卒業している人々ですけどね
来るのは いわゆる現場のお母さんよりもね
まあ子供の面倒を見ている人よりも
赤ちゃん持っている人よりは
まあもう子育て終わって
もう子離れもしているお母さんたちなんかを呼ぶ
家に呼んでご飯食べさせる
それだけ すごい便利です
だからそういう習慣はもう何の悪いこともないし
そのご飯の場合も普通とちょっと違う
作るご飯っていうのはね
大体ココナッツミルク入れてご飯炊いたりして
一応持って持ち運べるように作っておくんですね
そこら辺はちょっと違う思考
だからご飯というのは家で食べていくのは普通であって
人の家に行ってご飯を弁当作っていくのはすごい失礼なことなんですよ
その場合は持っていけるように用意して作るんです
で そういう儀式っていうことを知ってるんだから
お母さんたちが来て そういうもの
ワイワイといろんなことをやって
それで作った料理をちゃんと進んで家に持っていく
だからそこら辺は母の仕事ですね
やっぱり で どこかに出かけたら
帰る時は子供たちに食べ物は持って帰ると
で そこはもう家中みんなで食べる
だから 家からもらって
自分の家に帰ったら 自分の家にみんなに食べる
それぐらい分はあげます
とにかく配る時は 私も結構食べたことがあります
自分の母が他のどこかへ行ったら
行ったら期待してとにかく待っている
自分たちも時々子供 男の子たちも呼ばれる時ありますよ
この神様のいろんな儀式に男たち呼ばれたらお腹いっぱい食べて帰るだけなんです
お母さんには何もないんです
お母さんたち呼ばれたら必ず袋一つ持ってくるんです
これでまた待っているんだから
お母さんはいつでもかわいそうと
そこ そういう信仰 とにかくカーリーの信仰はインドの問題で
カーリ神を仏教徒にしたんですが
テーラワーダ仏教どこにもあるわけじゃないんです
インドでカーリ神の信仰はそれで仏教的になって変えたかというと
それほど変わってはないんですね
生贄だけはないんですから
これは仏教でなくてもできませんだからね
仏教も別に言うところじゃないよ
人を殺しちゃうと大変だから
どこでも それはないんですけど
動物を差し上げることはやってますし
ですから おそらくアングリマーラがこの人を殺して神に差し上げる
この一つの宗教儀式をやっていたんではないかと
だから彼にとっては犯罪
人殺しやではありませんと
大変な大事な聖なる儀式をやっていたんだと
ですから 同じ同業の宗教家が来て話し合うと
それは話し合いになります
何の違和感もないと そういうわけでチラッサンと言ったんじゃないかなと
久しぶりやと 自分一人で修行やっていたんだけど
長い間誰にも会わなかったところで会ってよかったっていう
それでこの神を 霊を信仰する宗教では
このギター する習慣があるんですね
全てこのもう精神病気の世界なんですけど
このこの神を自分で擬態する
擬態というんですかね
同じ形を見せる それはもうこういう変とこりんな信仰
宗教の信仰の世界ではいつでもあるんですよ
で 人相 神のことでは人間の妄想だから
神はこうである ああであるとか言うし
それ自分が神に朝から夜までずっとお祈りして
お祈りしてお祈りして
自分に神はもう現れたか乗り移ったかということは表現したいんですね
そうすると その擬態っていうことはやるんですね
で テレビで見たことなんですけど
もう韓国ではこの観音という信仰がすごい強烈にあります
まあまあ少宗派で キリスト韓国はキリスト教の国になったんだから
まあ一応仏教はまあ隠れているし
その中でも少宗派かもしれませんけど
一般民間宗教ですね 観音信仰
それで観音霊場とかなんかあったりして
だから観音っていうのはどんな形かというと
人間勝手に描くんですよ
で とにかく日本に来て
中国に来てから男でも女でもないものになったんだ
中国になってくるといくらか男なんですけどね
中国から離れると 男もなくなっちゃって
なんかもうどちらでもわからない変な形になってしまったんですが
だから韓国でも観音が男か女かわからないですが
とにかくこの時々女たちが観音乗り移ったと言って
手で八つの花を持って
もう中水のね 水筒なんとかと呼んで
こうやって踊ってるんですよ
その同じこうやってもう仕草しながら
それでみんなありがたい
ありがたい 観音様の降り移ったと
それで自分がイメージしている観音の形をもう一応踊って見せちゃうというか
精神的にはイカれてやる時もありますけど
わざとごまかしてインチキでやる時もありますけど
みんなインチキは嫌なんです
だからイカれてやる場合は信仰するんですね
確かに観音が乗り移ったと
で そういう笑い話でしょ
で 高野山とか行ってみてください
もう負けませんだから日本も
そういう連中っていくらでもいるんです
で 釈迦が乗り移って もう釈迦のふりをしている
もうイカれてる人がいるわ
もうあらゆるもう観音がを乗り移って
それで釈迦が喋る そこら辺いう精神イカれてる女たちですけど
釈迦が乗り移ったとかね
そういうのはまあ随分あります
それでジェズスが乗り移ったりする
キリスト教の世界でもあるしね
これを味わいたくて フィリピン人なんかはクナンオなんとかという日がありますね
なんとか日と言うんですけど
この 受難のその日になってくると
みんなこの十字架を背負って
頭に棘の冠をつけて もう行列に行くわ
時々打ってもらうんですよ
手に釘まで打って十字架を立たせてもらう
で まあ擬態は本気でやってほしいんだけど
やっぱりまず体を縛ってもらうんですね
それから手だけに釘をきちんと打ってもらう
こんな傷はと気にしない
いくら苦しいが それが受難は自分で味わってもらうことやと
何の意味かとは だから仏教は勝手にカシスを信仰するのはいいんだけど
今お釈迦様いないんだから困りますけど
お前そんなの意味が何の意味かと
あんたの頭に手に釘を打てなくても
神はあんたのことを守ってくれないかと
くだらんことをやるなよと言いたいところだけですよ
バカなことを 足にも打つ場合あるし
両手に打つんですよ どんどんと
すごいありがたい もうこれ上のない宗教儀式として何の意味もないでしょうね
そんなことで だからキリストを信仰するも
もうそれは勝手で何の問題はないんだけど
だからって その話が広げると
毎年毎年それやってもらいたくてやってもらえると
次から次へと精神病気の患者さんたちが出るでしょうね
そこでこの石一つ持って
こうやって自分の胸に投げて
叩きながらお祈りをする
お祈りはまではいいんだけど
あれ何の？これで怪我して血が mon mon 流れる
いくら怪我したって決まってる距離決まってる
お祈りの回数決まってる
この歩く道とかありますから
教会までそれはとにかくやり遂げると
そこでもう何の得もない行為だから
それちょいちょいとやめたんだから
神があっち向くんですかね
やらない人に対して神が親切じゃないんですかね
だからまあそんなのはいらんというね
ことなんですけど 宗教家たちがもうわざわざわざわざそのこれほど苦難受難しました
これほど受難しましたとか
そればっかり強調する
それでみんなに味わってもらいたくもなる
そういうのはもう病気でやりすぎで
社会には迷惑ということでね
この擬態業っていうのは
この この そういう迷信宗教にはもう必ずともある
日本でも密教系の世界やらね
真言系のね 世界に行ってみたら
もうプロの坊主じゃないんですよ
そこら辺におばさんたちがいて
おじいさんたちがいて
乗り移って だからその日本の場合は
この日本のお坊さんたちがそういうことを教えて人に目をかけてるっていうことはほとんどないんです
で これ こちらから巡礼に行く人々なんですよ
わざと人に目をかけようと計画を立てたのは弘法大師一人だけかもしれませんだけど
いろんな人間に迷信やら
いろんな儀式 儀礼 なんとか作ってはあげる
作ってはあげるというね
それも本人ではないと思います
いろんなところでね まあいろんな人が作った
それはまあ迷信 宗教に極普通にあることですね
擬態の世界 ですから このカーリの場合でも
この同じ擬態の世界なんですね
だからまあ首をつなげてというよりも
まあ首輪の方 指の首輪の方がまあかけやすいといえばかけやすいし
ある程度で神と同じ形にはなる
カーリの神と ですから
まあ本人がそういう神を擬態する
神を経験する あの まあ修行やったという
その象徴的なものではないかと
ある人物というよりも
そういうことであって
そちらに仏教という文化がぶつかってということではないかというね
ですから このわからないんですけど
とにかく 道が違うよと
すごい簡単に いつも簡単にその人はわかるんだからね
だからもともと頭が良くて
かなりの知識 学問能力ないとそう簡単にはわかるはずがないことだけは確かなんですね
ですから エピソードとして
仏教の場合はもともとすごい頭のいい子でしたと
他人にすごい羨ましがるような
ものすごい人でしたっていうことは
書いておいてのはそういうわけだと思いますね
で なきゃ そんな簡単に仏教の真理は認めるということにはなりませんし
だからすごくこの とにかく驚くのは一人出家したことだけは確かなんですよ
とにかくそれだけはね
で それにそれで戒律までできてますから
エピソードは完全に作ったものにはなりません
で あまり古くて エピソードからいろんなものをかけたり
付け加えたり かけたり付け加えたりだからね
それほど理解しにくいところもいくらかあるが
とにかくこの教典のポイントはそれで終わり
し あのまあ この動いているか止まってるかというたった二つの言葉で真理を語っている
だから動いている世界は苦しみの世界で
一切を詰まった世界がブッダが語る理想の世界であるという
その道か識かとかね その二言葉のからくりなんですね
ですから まあ物理的には動いていためんだか
いえ 自分が死だよと 物理的な視点
あなたは道ですよというところで成り立って
だから実際の本当の道って何なのか
本当の死って何なのかっていうことになり
話になって それでその人はまあ死の止まるの世界を正しいと分かっただけのことですね
だからとにかく動と止のこの二つの哲学思考で見ると
仏教の真理は正しいっていうことは当たり前になってくるんですね
だから動という世界は不安定だから
もうとにかく動かなくちゃいけないでしょうに
次から次へと次から次へと
何か何かして してしてしていかなくちゃいけない
納得いったならばそこでストップでしょうに
たとえいくら動いたっても
納得しましたらストップでしょう
だからストップの世界は止の世界こそが正しいんだよと
だから動を引き起こせばさらに動になるんだよと
何か行動したら そちらの影響で次にまた連鎖的に次の行動になりますね
ですから 動は動を生み出しますから
納得いくわけじゃいかない
いくら動を動かしても
ですから 停止というところでも
とにかく停止でよろしいというふうなことで
まあ論理は成り立ちます
それで話は終了します
[背景音]